I am going to Los Angeles California
tonight I'm going back into the belly of
the Beast I'm leaving the free state
for 48 hours and I'm going back to
California
to talk to Bill Maher so on Bill Maher's
podcast which is called Club random they
film it at his house that's where I'm
headed tomorrow Woody Harrelson you guys
know actor Woody Harrelson of cheers and
many other things over the years he's a
big pothead and he and Bill were smoking
some pot and talking about government
and Pharma and what I think is
interesting before I don't want to lead
it too much but what I think is
interesting about this is hmm couple
potheads sitting around realizing that
the government doesn't really do
anything good I like it most Americans
would not normally trust the government
with helping them you know like what
does the government actually do to help
you and they don't trust it they help
they help big corporations industry all
the people that got you know got those
people into Congress or ultimately to
become president those people all got to
get taken care of they don't trust the
CDC Americans we have the polling on
this is that true that is true okay so
here's the CDC promoting that we have to
do all of these things right I just I
don't like profiteering in war you know
think of the billions of dollars that
have gone to Big Pharma but I was
getting back to my original point the
last people I would trust with my health
his big Pharma and big government
because neither one of those strike me
as caring entities
I'd had Woody from cheers making some
sense going the libertarian route and
these are two guys who I think Woody
probably also lives in La I would guess
probably lives in California but Bill's
obviously right in the heart of LA and
Hollywood that whole thing and they're
they're getting it oh people don't trust
the government anymore they don't trust
the CDC and everything else now again
bill was for some of the lockdowns I
think at the beginning and four mass and
vaccines and all of those things I think
and I don't even need to fight about
every little thing with him but I'm
going to sit in that very chair tomorrow
and we'll talk about some of this stuff
but the point is uh what what do people
have to see at this point to realize
that the government does not work for
them and there is one set of political
we have two political main political
parties one set is just about expanding
the power of that thing and one is just
this imperfect usually pretty bad
version that is not really all for that
and sometimes can actually do some
really good stuff like here in Florida
that's kind of where we're at at the
moment and hopefully I'll get to share
some of those thoughts with Bill
tomorrow